I need to see those prices for missile
where we go today after I'm supposed to
disappear right back to this moment
promise
would you see her kid since company all
of our lives we're gonna be on the line
welcome to earth one my name is Cisco
Ramon want to tell me why the hell you
were time-traveling it to begin with I
needed to see this crisis for myself see
the amazing whole I don't understand you
Barry you marched towards death without
fear where is a you gain your strength
people that love
what do you want for your universe to
survive plant you destroyed it you
destroyed Nora's message unfortunate
side-effect but I needed to discourage
you from dome what hoping your
determination is boundless flash it is
one of your greatest qualities but you
cannot avoid the coming crisis mary has
five years before he vanishes no longer
December 10 to 2019 on that day he will
answer the call and make the ultimate
sacrifice
this world will fight for the fate of
all the known universes I'm not gonna
leave my family there has to be a way to
stop what's coming I am sorry but events
have been set into motion that you
cannot possibly comprehend I don't need
to understand them just tell me what I
can do to survive can't
in order for billions to survive this
coming crisis the flash must die
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my flash season 6 episode 2
trailer video barry going into the
future doing exactly what jay garrick
told him not to do then we finally get
jay garrick back so we'll break it all
down crisis on Infinite Earths we're
actually doing a new flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about the episode on the video starting
at the beginning here Barry tells Iris
in the cortex he's time traveling to the
day after he's supposed to die which
according to the monitor is December
10th this year that's also supposed to
be the day that the flash episode of the
actual crossover is happening in real
life the whole thing about the monitor
is that he said that in order for the
multiverse to survive not only would all
the heroes have to battle for its
survival but it was imperative that the
flash die a lot of you on my episode 1
video are like what if they just
substitute another version of Barry
Allen like the earth 90 version who's
played by John Wesley Shipp and he
sacrifices himself there's so many
people that are trying to find a way
around Oliver Queen having to die but I
think that completely circumvents the
whole point of the conversation that
Oliver had and the deal he made with the
monitor during last year's crossover
universe is a complex piece of machinery
and balance must be maintained one
change requires another how would you
propose I keep the balance will you help
me save Barry and Kara or not no but I
will give you the means to save them
tell me what you need an exchange
whatever the multiverse requires to
survive the crisis that is looming
when it is time so would you seems clear
right now that they want you to think
that Oliver is going to pull out some
big surprise and he will wind up
sacrificing himself in quote-unquote
disappearing that doesn't necessarily
mean that he's going to die it just
means that everyone thinks that he's
going to die in that there's a
gravestone in the future that doesn't
mean that there's a body in that grave
stone because it makes it sound like
he's going to be doing something on a
more cosmic level after he eventually
quote-unquote disappears but they don't
actually show you buried traveling to
the future in the trailer there is a
shot of the particle accelerator in the
previous trailers exploding but it's at
night so you can't tell if the skies are
red and remember it's Crysis so per that
newspaper all the skies are supposed to
be red that's just a countermeasure
either from the reverse-flash or from
the anti-monitor or from someone on his
team to block all the powers of the
versions of Superman and Supergirl then
we see him with Jay Garrick waking up
with Joan looking over him like his
mother so obviously this is a totally
different person because it seems like
they're on earth three based on the way
this is all decorated and she's not his
mother on earth three but she looks
exactly like her because she's an
alternate earth version I believe her
name in the episode is Joan Williams so
she might be married to Jay Garrick and
just have kept her maiden name but it
looks like she's a scientist and she's
sort of a version of Tina McGee on this
earth like the classic earth 90 flash
had Tina McGee helping him out with all
the science of it all Jay Garrick's only
told us a little bit about his backstory
I got a lot of questions on one of the
previous trailers as to whether or not
they ever had a son that looked like
Barry Allen on earth three and it sounds
like he did not because we probably
would have met that character already
but they probably don't want to recycle
too many twists because we made a
version of Barry Allen on earth too so
they don't want every single Barry to
show up on every single earth then
there's that crisis on Infinite Earths
scene with Barry in the Time Vault with
the monitor telling him and no uncertain
terms there's nothing he can do he
shouldn't try to avoid it
just make your peace with it because you
absolutely have to die in order for the
multiverse to survive he doesn't say why
or how that's going to happen all we
know from the future newspapers is that
it says flash vanishes in crisis and
everyone assumes that he's dead they
just talk about him like he's dying the
whole reason why he had to do that in
the comics is because the anti-monitor
had created this giant space gun
he was going to fire at Planet Earth
completely obliterated so Berry has to
run faster and faster than he ever has
around it to dismantle the weapon but in
doing so he goes so fast that his body
turns into pure speed force energy and
he seemingly disappears dying part of
the reason they did this is because they
wanted Wally West to become the main
version the flash a lot of the crisis
comic book in the 1980s was a transition
from the Silver Age of comics to the
modern age where a lot of the sidekick
heroes or the younger heroes sort of
came into their own became adults and
became the main versions of those
characters in the comics so that's why
you get to the Wally West era of the
comics Barry disappeared into the Speed
Force is pure energy for a little over
twenty years before he returned during
flash rebirth in 2009 pretty safe bet
that those circumstances around him
disappearing are gonna be different for
the TV show won't be some giant space
gun it'll be some other reason why he
winds up disappearing but in the future
that he's going to see during episode -
Oliver probably will have not done
whatever things he's going to do
differently to save Barry and prevent
him from disappearing so the flash
showrunner actually posted this comment
saying that basically we're going as if
Barry really is dying everyone's going
to assume that for the rest of the first
half of the season that means in Episode
three four five six so on so forth Barry
still thinks that he's going to die so
he sort of goes on his bucket list with
a lot of different team flash members
trying to pass on his knowledge and
prepare them for a world without the
flash as in a world without Superman
references if you're a longtime comic
book reader if you didn't read that
world without a Superman it's just the
story that came right after they killed
Superman off during the death of
Superman comic book there's also scenes
of Barry talking to the blood work
villain it seems a little weird watching
this after watching him freak out while
he was busy getting his powers usually
what happens on the flashes is that when
villains get their powers they hide it
for a little while then they start to
lose control and really turn into a
villain and that's when team flash gets
involved like it's clear that he has a
temper from his conversation with
Caitlin but he's on this grand quest to
defeat death literally stopped death
that makes it sound like he doesn't care
about forcing his cure on other people
if he could save people what does it
matter he had that whole conversation
with Caitlin even though I didn't
mention it in the video yesterday
I've talked about it during a couple
previous videos yes he is Mohinder from
the heroes TV series right now they're
still filming the crossover episodes a
lot of you were freaking out yesterday
because they posted a behind the scenes
picture of them on the Waverider with
grant gustin's flash Brandon rouse
Kingdom Come Superman and Tyler hoechlin
earth 38 Superman but even more people
were freaking out when they saw cress
Williams black lightning posing with
grant gustin's flash in a completely
different set this looks like an office
building but if you're not sure what's
going on and how this crossover is going
to work and how they're involving black
lightning yes this does mean now that
the black lightning TV show is
officially canon to the air overs
whereas before there was kind of a
question mark above it the showrunner
said that he didn't want to spend too
much time trying to crossover with the
arrowverse especially around last year's
crossover like we're doing our own thing
don't worry about it so you can see most
of those people in the background so if
there was any question of course this
confirms that the legends will be part
of the crossover but the actual legends
of tomorrow episode of the crossover
won't happen till the second half in
January when the shows come back from
the break and even though you don't see
Tom Wellings Superman and all this he's
probably somewhere in the background -
I'm assuming that his role now based on
the way they talked about it is bigger
than just a single episode cameo if
there any more crisis teasers or scenes
that drop this week I'll totally do
videos for it leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations preach Ragland you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
flash video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details everybody click here for
my flash season 6 episode 1 video and
click here for all my Joker movie Easter
eggs and ending scene thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight